PROFESSOR: So one of the
big mantras in any kind
of environment is testing.
You have to keep
testing your game,
because no plan meets first
contact with the user.
You have to be able to see
how real people are going
to respond to the
stuff that you're
making as soon as
possible, because many
of your assumptions going into
a project are going to be wrong.
Now, we encourage students to
go out and test their games
with as many people as
possible outside of class.
This is crucial for the
development process.
And there are a couple of
assignments where they actually
have to show us the
results of that testing.
And it's pretty much as
simple as sitting somebody
in front of a computer with
the latest version of the game,
or maybe with the paper
version of the game,
giving them a couple
of instructions
just so that they
can get started,
and then stepping back,
watching, and taking notes.
Trying to provide as little
guidance as possible,
so that they can
actually see how
a player who knows
nothing about the game
responds to it for
the first time.
However, sometimes it
can be difficult to get
a lot of testing done
outside of class.
And students may be a little
bit shy approaching strangers,
for instance, even
other MIT students.
So what we do also
in class is we
get different teams to
play each other's games
and give the feedback.
The quality of that feedback's
a little bit different,
because everybody the a room at
that point is in the same boat.
They are all making
games, and all
trying to give
feedback in the way
that a game developer
will give another game
developer, as opposed
to, say, a naive
player who just wants to have
a fun time playing this game.
We will also be giving
feedback as instructors.
We give them our experience,
both as developers
and this instructors.
And we can tell them,
that's a great idea,
but there's no way
you're going to get
it done within the amount of
time left in this semester,
because we've seen it.
We've seen how these projects
tend to go during the class.
No one else in the class
has gone through this class
multiple times.
So this is basically a way to
get feedback about the game.
And we teach students
various methods
to get the
information they want,
and to record it, such
as questionnaires,
for instance, different
observational techniques,
different ways to script the
process of getting a new user
to actually get started.
And most importantly,
the importance
of just doing this a lot.
PROFESSOR: So there are
a lot of different ways
you can do project management.
The one that we teach and
we favor at in our course
is we look at agile project
management techniques.
Most specifically, we look
at the one called Scrum.
And by the nature of agile,
agile project management really
requires a team to
work with itself a lot
to understand how the
team works together
and to understand each
of their team members'
strengths and weaknesses.
This is exactly not what we
give our students a chance
to do in the course
of the course,
unfortunately, because they
are working on short projects.
Each project tends to have
slightly different goals.
And they're changing
teams frequently.
So what we do do is we give
them a set of agile tools.
We introduce them to the concept
of backlogs, project backlogs,
creating very short
vision statements
to describe what the
goal of their project
is, but not go into a
whole lot of detail.
We have them make
project backlogs
that list all the features
they would like to have.
We have them take a look at how
they break that amount of work
down into how much can
we get done in a week?
And realistically
trying to figure out
how much they can get done
in a week, at which point
they realize their
project backlog
is about nine weeks long.
And they can trim
down from there
before they get started on some
of the less important things.
But we show them the tools.
We walk them through
using the tools.
And then we
encourage them to use
the tools that work best for
the group that they're with
and the project
they're working on.
So instead of saying,
this is how you do it.
Shunk.
We say, here are a set of tools.
Work with all of them.
Use the ones that work best.
And try to iterate not
just your project, but also
the way you are
managing your project
and the way you're working
together with each other.
Because that's the only way to
get to a better working team,
is to find out what works.
Accept that some of your
techniques don't work.
And try something new,
try something better,
until you do find what works
with that particular group
of people.
PROFESSOR: So we're
not only talking
about the tools and processes,
the hard skills when
it comes to project
management, but we're also
looking at iterating on their
soft skills, which often comes
down to just how do you talk
to another person respectfully?
We talk about team dynamics.
So teams tend to grow
in a particular way.
And often, there are shared
qualities that all teams have,
when it comes from forming
from when they're getting
their first conflict,
and trying to get over
their first conflict, to when
they're actually performing
pretty efficiently,
and then when
they feel like they're just
really kicking butt and really
moving forward.
We try to help them get
through to that final stage.
At best, they usually
get to right to the point
where they really
start performing along,
really start being efficient
in what they're doing.
But what we want to do is have
them see the whole process,
see how the stages
differ, and then,
come up with ways and approaches
to then get themselves
through the process,
and being able to talk
to their other teammates about,
maybe, a problem happened.
Maybe somebody didn't
check in some code.
And it caused two days
of work to go away.
There are better things to
do than just to rant and rail
at this other person.
So what are the
other things they can
do to get through that problem?
So we want them to
talk about that.
We want them to
think about that.
We talk about it a
little bit in class.
And we ask them to give us
what would they do again?
If they had do this again in the
future, what would they change?
What would they do differently?
So we're asking them
to do that through
their individual write-ups.
We ask for a lot of
reflection on the class,
on not just the game design
process, the game development
process, but also this
project management process,
and the communication between
team members, as well.